[Música]
jubilee presenta reunimos a 8 personas
que tienen cirugías plásticas me hice
cirugía plástica me hice cirugía
plástica en belice cirugía plástica me
hice a cirugía plástica me hice una
cirugía plástica me hice cirugía
plástica me hice cirugía plástica me
hice cirugía plástica una de ellas
miente si el grupo descubre al mentiroso
se dividirá en el premio
si el mentiroso sobrevive se lleva todo
el premio
quién es el impostor
deberíamos decir oye no soplábamos si
rinoplastia rinoplastia me quite grasa
del rostro y me rellene los labios
cuando lo hice sentí que la gente me
miraba de arriba abajo por fin me veían
como me quitaron lunares y ahora vengo a
eliminarlos a ustedes
veis una mastectomía rinoplastia
rinoplastia me hice varias rinoplastia
labioplastia y septoplastia la
rinoplastia es una cirugía clásica de la
nariz por lo general se elimina un bulto
de la nariz mueven las fosas nasales y
reducen su tamaño qué edad tenían
ustedes cuando se operaron
las millas fueron hace dos años si 18
tenía tratarlos tenía 19 estaba en
secundaria 22 24 hace ocho meses listo
votación quién es el impostor
es algo muy superficial pero siento que
no tenía en la imagen dijo que se había
operado las mejillas y ella nunca antes
había escuchado hablar de ese trabajo
muy bien es un empate entre tres globos
/ adelaide whisper y seis cada uno tiene
30 segundos para defenderse tenía muchas
inseguridades por mis mejillas redondas
y casi no tenía labios las operaciones
me ayudaron mucho ahora siento que si
puedo tener la cabeza en alto yo
necesitaba operarme para sentirme mejor
soy bailarina recibí una patada y mi
tabique se desvió me operaron para
reubicar mi tabique y poder respirar
pero también para eliminar una joroba
sigue siendo muy grande estoy consciente
de eso pero ahora puedo respirar me han
hecho exámenes para detectar cáncer
desde los 10 años porque mi papá murió
de melanoma cáncer de piel yo he tenido
lunares precancerosos que me han
eliminado con cirugía plástica para
reducir las cicatrices
[Música]
gracias chicos adiós suerte
probablemente hubiese hablado más de mis
consultas y de la experiencia que tuve
con mi doctor lo cómodo que me hizo
sentir algunos ya lo hicieron pero creo
que cada quien debería decir por qué se
hizo la cirugía sí claro bien mi perfil
me hacía sentir muy insegura tenía un
bulto en el tabique siempre quise una
nariz más derecha me hice rinoplastia y
septoplastia para poder respirar mejor
con anna no era tan obvio que tuviese
alguna cirugía sabía de qué hablaba pero
algo me decía que sólo estaba repitiendo
lo que decíamos todos nosotros me hizo
una mastectomía soy trans tenía grandes
senos así que un día dije ya no los
quiero fue por eso que me hice la
cirugía vengo de una familia muy
italiana así que tenía la típica nariz
italiana fue un procedimiento cerrado
entraron por el interior quitaron la
coroba y modificaron la punta y ahora
tengo una nariz recta
si habían demasiadas chicas con
rinoplastias éramos muchas ana y miranda
respondieron de forma muy convincente la
de yale fue un poco mas estereotípica y
para ser honestos mencionó que le
quitaron un bulto de su nariz pero
todavía se le nota nunca me gustó mi
nariz le pedí la cirugía a mis padres y
no me dijeron les pregunté si podría los
18 me dijeron que claro que si todavía
quería hacerlo me ayudarían a pagarla
perfecto cuando cumplí 18 lo volví a
mencionar y ellos de verdad no pensaban
todavía quería hacerla claro que quería
así fue que me operé la primera fue como
la tuya más correctiva muchos no saben
que es una labioplastia es una cirugía
del área vaginal que estrecha la piel
dos años más tarde terminé haciéndome
una rinoplastia fue sobre todo por
razones estéticas participaba en
concursos de belleza y quería verme
mejor y tener más confianza en este tipo
de ambientes todos pueden hablar de sus
cirugías libremente porque nadie te
juzga con el pasar de los años me siento
más cómoda hablando de mi cirugía
para los que tuvieron que pagar ha
contado cuánto les terminó costando todo
el seguro cubrió algo pero mis padres
pagaron entre 8 y 10 mil cuánto cubrió
el seguro a la parte respiratoria por la
investigación del tabique cubrieron sin
eso a mí me inyectan relleno porque la
revisión no salió también
pero a la primera operación costó nueve
mil dólares cuánto tiempo esperaste para
la revisión a la cirugía fue en el
verano antes de comenzar el primer año
de secundaria la revisión fue las
vacaciones de invierno de mi último año
y yo usé mi dinero fueron cuatro mil 500
dólares siempre creí que debías tener
mucho dinero para hacerte una cirugía
plástica y también creía que era algo
cosmético no sabía que podía ser
correctiva todavía tenía el seguro de
mis padres cuando lo hice y no sé no
tengo idea de cuánto costó siquiera
parte estaba cubierta porque michelle
aceptó y la reina al mismo tiempo ana
dijo que una parte la cubrió el seguro y
otra parte no y me quedé
está bien pero hace cuánto fue eso
cuando te hiciste la cirugía cuando te
recuperas te todavía tenía muchas
preguntas no tenía seguro y fueron diez
mil mi primer trabajo en la secundaria
poco a poco se hizo muchos ahorros y
sientes que hay un estigma con la
cirugía plástica o si las personas
siempre creen que eres vanidoso y
sobre todo si es por algo cosmético y
ronda de eliminación doble
[Risas]
[Música]
adiós chicos
santos cielos chicos
probablemente muchos no saben sobre
cirugía cosmética en lunares
creo que es también la luna y por eso me
echaron levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue en caja y les gustaría
seguir en el juego creo que es muy
pronto
dime quién dirías que fue la persona que
más te apoyó durante toda la
recuperación mi mamá sí y yo igual igual
mi mamá dormí en mi cuarto por toda la
primera semana porque yo estaba
agonizando y no dormía bien siempre creí
que era un ángel por hacer eso yo
la hice escondidas de mi mamá no quería
que lo supiera no quería que nadie le
dijiste a otras personas cercanas o no
me gusta que me lista porque la verdad
no me apoyaban tanto como quería no
quería que supieran que me la iba a
hacer no quería que me trataran de
detener no quería que el estigma
negativo me convenciera de no hacerla
así que fue algo que hice por mi propia
cuenta mis padres en verdad me apoyaron
mucho al principio no les encantaba la
idea
especialmente por nuestra identidad
judía hacer la nariz más pequeña y
quitar el bulto borrar tu cultura judía
lo que no les agradaba pero luego de la
cirugía fueron muy amables y me apoyaron
de verdad entiendo lo del origen porque
soy mitad libanesa y muchos de mi
familia tiene narices distintivas y uno
de mis primos me preguntó si tuvieras
hijos y tuvieran ese bulto les dirías
que se lo quiten ese médico es como
estoy arruinado
creo que hay un equilibrio entre aceptar
quién eres y reconocerlo si necesitas
cambiar algo porque te dará mucha más
confianza entonces hazlo no importa que
te juzguen quién te apoyo y mi mamá por
supuesto ella fue quien me cuido todos
sabían pero menos mi papá aún no lo sabe
ahora lo sabrá literalmente al enviar el
enlace porque a sus ojos soy su hija soy
hermosa él jamás jennifer y hacerme una
besaría así que no pude tenía miedo de
decirle ustedes dirían que impactó sus
vidas de alguna forma cambió algo mi
confianza desde luego suiza si en un
100% bueno para mí también fue ser
transgénero como dije crecí michigan y
eso no era bien visto claro así que fue
complicado no solo hacerme la cirugía
sino también salir como transgénero pero
ahora pienso me veo fabuloso vayamos a
la playa oa europa
creo que antes era más prejuiciosa cómo
o por qué usas tanto maquillaje todos
los días y ahora yo uso maquillaje las
decisiones de los demás en cuanto a su
autoestima creo que ahora tengo más
empatía por ellas porque el dolor que
tuvieron que pasar y pasar por lo mismo
que yo
fue muy duro y ahora entiendo que las
personas pasan por mucho para fortalecer
su autoestima claro
ah
adiós chicos
es algo difícil de contar mi historia es
la de una típica rinoplastia pero bueno
tal vez fue por eso que me eliminaron
levanten la mano si piensan que el
impostor sigue en la caja y quieren
seguir jugando
creo que lo logramos empecé a dudar de
nuevo mi sexto sentido me decía que
ganara la impostora y luego empecé a
dudar de miranda porque creía que estaba
ahí para confundirnos a todos tenían las
cirugías
típicas y perfectas bueno eso sonó mal
si las luces se tornan verdes eliminaron
al impostor si se tornan rojas el
impostor sigue en la caja y perdieron
el
impostor da un paso adelante
[Risas]
y
sentía sus miradas sobre mí me sentí
como un proyecto de ciencias y ellos
estaban como
siento que tenía los conocimientos podía
ponerme específico pero ellos no me
creyeron
y claro nadie iba a decir que no era
transgénero lo supe desde que accedí a
esto sabía que era mi entrada dorada no
tenía duda de que llegaría al final
trabajamos duro y
siento que gané la lotería a pesar de
que soy de las personas que dicen que no
hay nada que te indique que alguien
tiene una cirugía hoy aprendí a entender
mis propias creencias y apreciaciones
porque mientras yo los miraba a todos
pensaba quién parece tener alguna
operación aquí así que deberías revelar
mi forma de pensar no siempre se trata
de cambiar cómo te ve el mundo sino de
sentirte cómoda con tu cuerpo creo que
muchos piensan que las personas que se
hicieron cirugías son inseguras y
vanidosas no creo que sea cierto es algo
muy valiente decidir cambiar tu cuerpo
con el propósito de amarte a ti mismo
mucho más jubilee abraza la empatía